je serai et des léopards aller au parc
commune par le congo qui tarde à 3 et 6
mois
je fais aussi du jeu transformé en 89
100 % on se ressemble sans fausse
enrichie ces fassis pro cette question
là car sa démarche comme ça mais l'outil
brown pour la danse à l'oubli
l'émerveillement voilà je suis mon fils
aux femmes de moins de 50 ans oui mais
il faut bien traiter les gens à
l'émerveillement c'est dira jamais assez
dès que faire un moteur de crysis très
haché trop distraire soit l'impression
que ce moment je n'en dirai pas plus
waouh je fêterai quoi un des plats du
coup un frère des sous pour nous avoue
je me prends pas la tête on la
traduction vous avez qu à mobiliser cdu
manière
jarry qu'aux clients
[Musique]
elle est brillante et un mot pour la
remise pour la room et d'expérience
franchement le meilleur album du moment